there are lots of questions now about
where we are at in the pandemic and when
it comes to england where the plan b
restrictions will be lifted soon there
is still a high rate of infection the
latest ons figures show an estimated 4.3
million people in the uk had covered in
the first week of january that's about
one in 15 in england and one in 20 in
other parts of the uk but if we look at
london hit hard by omicron we can see
infection rates here are starting to
plateau in the northwest cases are
continuing to rise but much more slowly
overall the numbers are high but in this
wave we have the vaccine two that means
if you compare hospital admissions from
the second wave last january to hospital
admissions in the current wave you can
see that the numbers are much lower now
they are still high though the latest
figures show a rolling average of over 2
000 people admitted to hospital each day
in the first week of january the figures
also show the number of hospitalizations
is starting to slow down hospitals are
just about coping but there is a lot of
pressure on the nhs
another important thing to look at is
the number of people dying so compare
the second wave with the situation now
and you can see how the numbers are
lower this time but we are still seeing
over 200 deaths a day how close are we
to the end of the pandemic have we
reached an acceptable stage of the virus
well it doesn't feel like it yet but we
definitely seem to be heading in the
right direction